Accelerated flight. In accelerated flight it's important to try to keep your hands
right at the top. If you want, you can also hold lightly onto the
risers, because in accelerated flight we can only steer with weight shift.
And if that's not enough, then we add a very light pull
on the lowest riser as well. So that's accelerating, or how
do we accelerate. Once I'm comfortably into the first stirrup, you go
with your heel into that first loop, you twist a bit so that with the
second foot you can step back onto the next bar, and then the second foot
also comes back onto that bar. You see, I have it on the flexible system, most
of you, if you have a rigid bar, find it a bit easier. Yeah, then we look for that
symmetry with the feet, and then we press the accelerator slowly,
smoothly. And ideally the accelerator, like the one on the right, ends up roller
on roller, or at least roller against roller. Here on the left,
there's still a bit of distance between the individual rollers.
There can also be reasons for that, because we have an asymmetry in the risers,
and once I push the legs out further, you see, that's where we get the symmetry and the rollers
meet up. That would be full bar, and now the important thing: steer only with
weight shift, and if that's not enough, then we may very lightly pull on the
rear riser. So one centimetre, two at most, really just a tiny amount of work.
Good, coming out of the accelerator, simply sit back to neutral, or if we're doing a turn
to the other side, finish that first and then sit back to neutral. And slowly
back off the accelerator. The last few centimetres of riser travel, that's where we ease off.
What's important during accelerated flight is not to steer with the
brakes. The explanation for that comes later in the section on the brakes.